Congratulations, you've now got a working search engine.
You can crawl the Web, finding content from pages, building an index,
and then respond to search queries with the pages that contain that content.
This is really exciting. I think I'm ready to start my search company.
Cool. And so I was looking at the competitors out there, and the key is that you've got to have a catchy name.
So Google, Duck Duck Go. I've got to come up with something.
This is the really hard part. Yeah. I'm ready to announce -- I'm ready to share with you my idea.
I've been putting a lot of thought into this. How about Search With Peter dot Info?
Oooh. Yeah. So there's a lot of work to do. I've got to buy servers.
I've got to get employees. Investors. I've got to -- Oh, man -- I should probably start now.
Okay. Well, good luck to Peter. There are some more things that we want to learn in this class.
And there's some things we need to do to really improve the search engine to make it useful.
In Unit 5 we'll work on making the search engine faster.
And in Unit 6 we'll work on making it find the best page for a given query, not just all the pages.
So for the rest of this unit we're going to look at understanding more how the Internet works
and what happens when we request a page on the World Wide Web.